- So, Daniel, you and Troy were roommates
while shooting the movie, right?
- [Daniel] Oh yeah, we were.
- [Troy] Yes, we were.
- I gotta be honest, with you,
that had to be one hell of an experience
'cause he seems like fun.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Daniel]
Obviously, he is a lot of fun,
you can see.
- [Troy] Daniel and I,
so we wanted to be roommates
because they were going
to separate us in a hotel.
And we really wanted to
benefit from the experience
of being roommates, like father and son.
And we were able to chat,
how to pick up women
and advice I'd give him about clothes
to different types of
fishing boats and so on.
And so we moved into an
Airbnb together as roommates
and we were really excited,
you could see the water
and the boats going by in the harbor.
It was really cool.
And at night we were trying
to switch all the lights on.
And so we saw these lights
slowly starting to switch on
and we went outside
and we sat on the patio.
- And it was beautiful.
- [Troy] Then what happened?
- [Daniel]
It looked beautiful.
So we were just looking
around, we were so excited.
We're here at the "CODA" movie.
We're discussing all of our ideas
and then, you know, we
can see a cop pull up
with strobe lights and he
walks up to the front door.
And really the cops are
here, so Troy and I get up
and we're nervous and we run downstairs.
We're deaf, we can't hear,
we're telling them from the balcony.
And they're like, "Okay."
And they walk up to the front
door, we let 'em in the house.
We start writing, back
and forth with the cop.
- [Troy] So, they said,
"There is a blaring
foghorn from your house
that's been going off for hours."
(crowd laughs)
And we said, "Really?"
So the neighbors were complaining
and calling the cops and we didn't know,
we were just enjoying ourselves
as the foghorn was blaring.
(crowd laughing)
And we didn't know how to switch it off.
- [Daniel] I
mean, we felt so peaceful.
We can feel bass, but we
couldn't hear that foghorn.
We had no idea,
we were having the most
beautiful, peaceful night
but really we were
destroying our neighbors.
(crowd laughing)
- [Troy]
Yeah and so we were trying
to figure out how to switch it off.
And so we were trying
all the light switches
and then they looked all the same.
So one of the light switches
was actually the foghorn.
So that's where the big screw up was.
- [Kelly] Oh my.